recent weeks have seen an unprecedented
flurry of diplomacy efforts have
intensified as the threat of war grows a
war many believe could now be imminent
and very dangerous
meanwhile troops tanks and weapons
continue to mass in eastern europe
russian forces surround ukraine nato is
reinforcing its members that border
russia while some members of the
alliance but notably not germany are
sending anti-tank and anti-aircraft
missiles to ukraine
so is there now a way to stop this march
to war
sven jurgensen is estonia's ambassador
to the united nations his country is a
neighbor to russia and until the end of
last year served on the security council
there is always room for compromise but
the question is does russia want to
compromise because if you look at the
demands that russia has put forward to
united states and nato then just reading
through them it's absolutely obvious
that this all is just nonsense it's
deliberately drafted in a way
that there couldn't be any compromise
the leader of another nato nation again
with a border with russia norwegian
prime minister jonas gastore has told me
despite the difficulties no efforts
should be spared to find a diplomatic
solution
i simply state and i observe that now
there are talks going on there's a
channel of communication and i would
appeal to those who sit at those tables
use those channels at the maximum and on
the nato side and the euro atlantic side
i believe there is very strong unity on
the principles and very clear messages
in the communication
the problem is that russia's foreign
minister sergey lavrov has made his
country's demands in public
and in writing russia says ukraine must
never join nato and that poland and the
three baltic states which are all nato
members mustn't be allowed to have
troops or weapons from other nato
countries on their soil
the main question is our clear message
that we consider further nato expansion
to the east and weapons deployment which
can threaten the russian federation
unacceptable
one expert on the region warns there can
only be a compromise if russia tables a
new proposal something that's more
palatable to nato the best compromise
would come if russia put something else
on the table that the west was willing
and able to provide
if russia looks at the general state of
unity between europe and the united
states if it looks at the kind of
economic measures that have been
promised in case of an incursion and
decides that that cost isn't worth it
that the need to maintain
business and and economic ties to europe
is important enough for where russia
wants to be in the future
that jeopardizing that isn't worth it
some experts believe that president
putin may not have decided yet whether
he's going to invade ukraine the first
meeting of the un security council on
the current crisis is expected on monday
and russia will be looking for the
support of china and that's why some
diplomats believe the russians may wait
to launch military action until the
event that china cares so much about the
beijing winter olympics is over in
mid-february james bay's al jazeera at
the united nations